hello everyone i am bank and welcome to
simply learn today we will take you
through the hands-on lab demo of data
analysis using python and taking the top
thousand instagram influencer data set
before we start i hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
i'm repeating again i hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
we have regular updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technology stands
then consider that getting subscribe to
our youtube channel and press that bell
icon to never miss any update from
simplylearn
it i think we can get started
in today's session we will go through
the data analysis using python
we already have a data set with us where
we have data of top thousand instagram
influencer we will analyze this data set
using python before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss data
analysis and the steps and the
importance of the same
data analysis is a process for acquiring
arranging and changing data so that
prediction about the future and the
data-driven decision can be made
finding potential answer to business
problem is also helpful
let's move forward and see steps to
perform data analysis
so first one is define the question what
commercial issue are you attempting to
resolve by raising it as a query you can
concentrate on coming up with a precise
response
and the second one is collecting data
to answer specified research question
test hypothesis and evaluate outcomes
data collection is the act of acquiring
and measuring information on variables
of interest in a systematic and defined
manner
and the third one is cleaning data
your data should be explored cleaned up
and
deducted and organized as unnecessary do
whatever needs to be done but wait a
moment give it some time
and the fourth one is analyzing data
perform a variety of analysis to gain
insights
concentrate on a descriptive diagnostic
predictive and prescriptive types of
data analysis
and the fifth one is visualization and
sharing your findings how can you most
effectively impart your knowledge and
suggestions
the trick is using communication and
visualization technologies together
after seeing the steps to perform data
analysis let's move forward and see some
importance of data analysis
so
python is a high level open source
interpreted language that offers a
fantastic approach to object oriented
programming
it is the one of the greatest language
for a variety of projects and
applications according to data
scientists working with mathematical
statical and scientific function is a
base with python it provides top-notch
libraries for working with data science
application
python is the one of the most widely
used programming language in the field
of science and research due to its
simplicity and use
this means that even those without
engineering skills might quickly learn
how to utilize it furthermore it works
better for rapid prototyping
there are some most common libraries
used for data analysis the first one is
numpy
pandas
matplotlib
scipy
seaborn
and many more
so
so what do you guys think about data
analysis do share your thoughts with us
in the chat section
now let's move to our programming part
to perform data analysis using python so
first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so we will write jupyter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of jupiter
notebook and select open
new python file
so this is how the ui looks like so at
first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in mathematical functioning so the first
one is numpy
number is a python library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices
it is an open source projected and you
can use it freely
numpy stand for numerical python so we
will write
import
numpy
as nb
so here nb is denoting numpy
so we will import the next libraries
pandas pandas is a software library
written for the python programming
language for data manipulation and
analysis in particular it offers data
structures and operations for
manipulating numerical tables and time
series so we will write
import
pandas
as pd
here
pd is for denoting pandas so we will
f cluster
so after importing the libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write data
equals to pd dot
read
underscore csv
and here we have to write our data set
name
data set
insta
dot csv
press shift plus center yeah
here pd is for pandas library read is
used for reading the data set
from the machine and csv is used for the
type of file which you want to read
so then we can write data to see our
data
so
see this is how our data set look like
so let's first rename this column name
followers
this one followers in million by writing
followers only because it is so lengthy
and this followers column we are going
to use most of time so it will save our
time
so we will write
here
data
dot rename
column
equals to
that curly braces
here we will write
the name of column which you want to
rename followers
yes
colon
to followers
so here we will write in place
equals to true
okay then here we will write data
okay does not change yet
okay okay because it is follow words
to give one space here
yeah done
so
rename function is a function which is
used to rename the column name so there
are many keywords arguments like index
column access copy in place level errors
which you can use as a parameter so
column name is changed to followers
let's move on so here you can see the
three dots this one
and we are unable to see our full data
like only we can see the 10 rows so
like we have thousand rows right so for
that we can write
here we can write
pd dot set
underscore options
display
dot max
underscore columns
and here we can write
none
after that this is for columns and we
can write for the same for the rows
sort underscore options
it is option not options
okay we can write here display
dot max
underscore for rows
oh perfectly done okay we can write here
none
so pandas features and options this one
system that allows you to modify various
aspects of their behavior users are most
likely to change display related options
so the maximum number of rows by default
is 10. you can see one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so the
maximum number of rows by default is 10
all rows of data frame are considered if
the value is set to none
set the display value by setting x max
rows to none and passing it to the set
option all rows from the data frame will
be shown
so
let's move on
and see our full data
by writing data frame name here
so
okay let me debug the error
okay here column name
lu
mns
okay sorry
so
here we can write data
so see this is how our data look like
the thousand rows
with full thousand rows like
from 999 to zero
yeah
so moving ahead here you can see the nn
values like this
nan
and below nan and n so n means not a
number and it is one of the typical
methods for representing the data set
missing values
it is a unique floating point value and
can only be changed to the flow type
so
let's change it to 0 for the better
result and the better prediction so we
will write here
data
dot fill
n a
0
so by writing this we will shift plus
enter
so all any values are now changed to
zero with the help of this fill n a
function this fill and a method replaces
the null values with a specified value
so after this let's move on to the
another function which is shape
so we will write data dot shape
then shift plus enter yeah so this shape
function will return you a number of
rows and columns your data set have
so here we have thousand rows you can
see
and seven columns
yeah
so let's move on to the another amazing
function which is info
so here we will write data
dot info
perfect so data frames information is
printed by the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use range
index and another number of cells in
column
note that the information method does
indeed print the information
so here you can see all information has
been printed like all the columns name
all the non-null values count and data
types
for the particular column
so
let's move forward and see our next
function which is data dot columns so
which is data
dot columns
okay again i wrote wrong
luminous
okay perfect so as per the name you can
easily tell me in the chat section what
is going to print for us
so
this function is going to print all the
columns name so here we have names like
name rank category followers audience
country authentic engagement engagement
average data type is object why data
type is object data type is object
because this is taking as the one
category that is why it is taking as
object so let's move forward for the
next function which is describe
so data frame comprises of numerical
data
and each column's description includes
it following details
like count is the total amount of non
empty values mean
the standard deviation and many others
so here we will write data
dot
describe
open brackets
so
see
so here you can see all the columns
which have numerical data is displayed
by the full description
so this is our mean
count study minimum 25 percent of the
particular date column 50 and 70 percent
and the maximum value
present in the column so moving forward
let's solve some questions like how to
show audience country like from which
country we have the most number of
followers so let me write
this question as a comment so for
comment we have to use hashtag
so here you can write how to show
audience
from
pitch
country
we have
most
number
of followers
okay perfect
yeah
so so let's solve this with a small line
of code we can write here data
here column name as audience
entry
dot
value
underscore
counts
normalize
equals to true
then we will round it
it to
[Music]
two
okay here we have to write the capital t
perfect
yeah
so
returns an object with counts of
distinct value the resulting object will
be arranged in descending order with the
first element being the one of the that
appears most frequently by default
exclude any values index value count
normalize equals to false sort equals to
true ascending equals to false or bins
equals to none
is a syntax of counting values the
normalized function
in python processing package is used to
normalize the data it accepts an array
as input and converts its content to a
range between 0 and 1.
after that it will give a back an output
array with the same size of input array
if we remove round function it will show
the output like it is still showing the
values
but we round this value for how many
decimal places we have to see the value
that is why i has written two here for
two decimal places so we will write
here
yeah the data look like good
so from this question we can say
maximum audience is from united states
with like 28 percent
followed by india like 16 percent and
brazil 15 and so on
so
let's move to the our next question
which is how to show audience country
like who is having more followers from
india or a particular country
so
let me write it as a comment
so
how
to
audience
okay
this is three
hashtag
so
audience
country
like who is
having
more
followers
the question is that like who
which influencer is having more forwards
from india
so
don't worry we will
like do for the more and more countries
so
here i have to write data
underscore
ind for india
so equals to data
again data this is our data frame name
so
audience
tree
here we can write double squares to
yeah
here we can write data
so here we are giving data ind name of
you can say our variable name and data
is our data frame name and audience
country
is column name and india is a country
name from which we want to collect
influencer
so
let me
do this
let me debug the error audience country
okay c is capital here
yeah perfect
so
these all influencers are
who has audience from india so like
christian or virat kohli that khabib
justin bieber instagrams in iraq
and so on
so so let's take another country this
time we will take united states
so we will write here data
underscore usa
okay data
data again
and
audience
sees capital now country
perfect
equals to equals to
it is usa or united state
in the united states perfect
so
united
states
so
data
dot
usa
this time i am using
uh
score
and dot head
so
we have to write same code like we did
for india here i have used the head
function
you can see the head function
to show only five first rows
you can also write only data usa so to
see the full data
so i will write like this i can do like
this so
here i can see the full data
the influencer who belongs to united
states that audience country who belongs
to united states
so
i will control that
or
head function
yeah
so
okay let's do for one more country
brazil
so let's
write
data data
underscore brazil
pursue
data
again data
an audience
is capital country
equals equals to
oh brazil how it is returned
[Music]
so here we will write brazil
is capital forgot
azil so here we will write data
underscore
brazil
so we have to write same code like we
did for india and usa so
here let me use a function called tail
so
here i have used the tail function to
show only last five rows head will show
you the first five rows and the tail
will show you the last five rows so you
can also write only brazil to see full
data so let's move forward and see our
next question which is
like how to show audience for a
particular category
so let me write this
question as a command for your better
understanding and readability
so here we will write
how
to show
audience
for a particular
category
okay
so this time i will use fashion category
so let's write code for this one so
fashion
equals to data underscore usa
data
underscore usa
right here
category
okay dot str
dot
contains
write your fashion
that's
yeah here i'm using the data usa set for
retrieving the fashion category we can
do this for all the data using our data
frame name we can also write data only
here so
i have given the column names as a
category and str contains
means string which contains fashion this
is what we have to print and any should
not be false
okay so let's see
if white is showing this
data underscore usa
okay here f is capital
capital
so
yeah
perfect
see these all influencers which have
audience from united states like kendall
jenner zandiya and beyonce
so these all influencers which have
audience from united states and belong
to some kind of fashion industry
so moving ahead let's take one more
category this time we will take sports
category because sports is something
like
which most of people like so we will
write here sports
pursuit data
this time we will take india data set
ind i guess we have road the same
yeah
so here we will write data
underscore
id
and
category
same str dot contains
we will write here
we check one thing
so sports s is capital
sports
sports
again
okay this time we will use sports dot
hat
so this time i use india data and all
the things are same just replace fashion
with the sports so
see these are all the influencer
cristiano virat kohli
khabib sharma hardik pandya
which have audience from india and
belong to some kind of sports industry
so as i'm talking before like we can use
data frame name for all data instead of
using
like india data or
like this one so we can also write like
this data only
okay let me create one more
for the
or only data so we can write like here
sports
so data
here we can
it here we are like taking our data like
full data frame name
so
we can write
category
category name
so
dot str dot contains
contains
quotes
comma n a
equals to
false
okay here we will write spot
okay
so as i am talking before like we can
use data frame name so instead of like
writing only data and your data usa
brazil
so these influencers like from sports
category belong to any one country
so
this is our full
influencer category so let's move
forward and
do this again for the music category
like because music is also one of the
favorite category of you folks
so
we have to write music
okay music
equation
we will do is for the whole data so data
data
category
cr dot
contains
i guess m is capital in music
yup
it's capital so music
n equals to
so this data will contain all the
category influencer name which belongs
to music category whether they are from
india usa brazil or any other country
doesn't matter
see you can see indonesia south korean
so moving forward let's change our some
column data types to integer type
so we can write here data
equals to
data
dot s type
round bracket then curly braces so here
we can write
followers
if followers forwards
and then it should be changed to integer
and take it from here authentic
engagement
overcome the spelling mistakes so i can
take from here
in teaser
uh
let's do for one more engagement average
so
integer
okay
so here we can write data dot hat
yeah perfect
all the columns change to incisor type
now so
this is how we can change like data type
and column
here like data is our data frame name
this one
and the as type
this one as type
is the method like which gives a back a
new data frame with the requested data
type for the data to select a data type
for each column you can either cast the
entire data frame so that the type
or i use python dictionary like in the
following example like calories pulse or
whatever respectively
i repeat calories per decision are all
like integers value respectively
so let's move to our next question which
is like top 20 category by follower
before making graph for this one let me
create like top variable followers
so
[Music]
here i can write
like 20 top
20
followers
to
data
dot enlargest
and largest
like we need 20 so we can write here
i am writing followers spelling like
this because we have to like this follow
us f o l w e rs
so
perfect
yeah so top 20 followers we have taken
as a variable name to store followers
and to obtain the first and rows
arranged by the column in descending
order
use of the enlarges function
which is this one and largest function
specified columns are also written uh
i repeat but they are not used to
determine anything
so data frame dot enlarges you can write
the syntax like this self comma like n
comma column names or keep you can also
write keep equal to first so
top 20 followers are generated uh let me
create graph so
[Music]
first we will import
library
like one of the main library for
visualization which is
matplotlib
so for importing this we have to write
import
okay
so
we can also write
like
instead of writing import we can also
write from
matplotlib
import
so for the python programming language
and it's some pi numerical mathematics
matplotlib is a graphing library with
the help of general purposes like gui
toolkits like tinker
python qt and gtk it offers an object
oriented api for embedding plots into
applications
so
after this let's create
the figure so we have to write plt dot
figure
that again figure size
equals to
you can take 12 and 8
perfect
so we will get figure
2 here
equals to
plt dot
bar
top
20
but we have take
followers
dot
category
comma category
top
20
followers
okay followers
what
followers
comma like label should be
should be
followers
it
should be
like i'm taking 0.8 here
and my favorite color is
maroon
so i will take
my own color
so
plt
dot x6
font size
could be like 12
and rotation
should be 90
perfect
so let's create y and x labels so plt
dot y label
followers
followers
font size
should be let me take 16 here
and lt.text label
category
and the font size should be font size
so
16.
so
let's set the title for this now for
plt.ti
title
is
top
20.
categories
the words
comma
font size
should be
let's
take it as 20
and plt dot
underscore layout
layout
this one and we can write plt dot
tick
label underscore format
this
equals to
y
y
style should be
plain
okay
so this is how the visualization look
like here i have used
the
bar graph for this visualization and top
20 followers dot category and this one
top 20 followers dot followers
are the x and y values
and color is something like which color
you want to show with and you can choose
as your preference and x and y labels
are used to print in x and y coordinate
like this followers in millions and
category
so this tight layout
this one this tight layout
and
i repeat
this tight layout function this one
this tight layout function this one
this tight layout function in pipeline
module of matplotlib library is used to
automatically adjust subplot parameters
to give a specified padding
so plt dot tick label format is used for
in which axis or in which style you want
to print plt dot tick label is not
necessary to write or to showing
paragraph
so
like
when we can remove this so our
visualization should look like this
so it is not necessary
okay
tools that
so let's move to our next question like
using bar graphs
let's see how our category look likes so
first we will create
i'm writing here
showing
categories
using
pie chart
so using
using pie chart let's see how our
category look like
first we will create categories
so we have to write here
like types
equals to data dot
category
dot
value
underscore
counts
and this one
yeah
types
okay
types
dot
reset
underscore index
here we have used types as a variable
and value counts like we already
discussed before
so these all are the categories
from our data
so
let's create the pie chart now so for
plotting a pie chart we have to write
plt dot pi
like types
dot values
values comma label
should be
types
dot index
this one
label should be type dot index this
music cinema lifestyle modeling and so
on
so
index
comma
label distance
equals to 1.2
and then auto
pct
should be
like
percentage 1.2
f
percentage percentage so
like
shadow
should be true
perfect and let me
add one more thing start
right angle
should be
60
okay so plt dot
title
is like
you can say different
categories
comma font size
should be
20
and that's plt dot
plot
so let me check everything is correct
values labels
okay
here we can write labels
type dot values labels
equals to type dot index and label
distance equals to 1.2
so here auto pct is equals to
[Music]
like
okay shadow equals to true perfect and
starting is good 20
60
so plt or title different categories
okay okay fine everything is great
so
it's not coming okay perfect so this is
how our pie chart look like this is
looking like a mess because we have more
than 100 categories that is why like 100
percent is splitting into 152 categories
like you can see here
we have 152 categories
okay
so
this is how
sorry this is how our
like pie charts look like for different
categories let me try d capital
yeah perfect
so i hope you guys must have understood
the concept of data analysis using
python
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this live session please do
subscribe to our youtube channel and
give like to this video
thank you and keep learning
[Music]
you